sal y es una arquitecta que crea un
plano de un comedor rectangular el área
del comedor en la vida real el área es
1.600 veces más grande que el área del
comedor en el plano hay que tener
cuidado no nos están diciendo que la
escala es 1600 a uno sino que la razón
de las áreas es de 1600 vale bueno la
longitud del comedor en el plano es de 3
pulgadas cual es la longitud del comedor
empieza ok vamos a estudiar esto con un
poquito de más calma qué sucede con la
escala de las áreas o con la razón de
las áreas cuando tenemos una escalada da
para eso deja de dibujar aquí un plano
que para hacernos una idea vamos a
ponerlo de uno por uno y vamos a pensar
qué sucede qué sucede con el comedor
imagínate que por acá está el comedor
entonces qué pasaría si la escala fuera
uno a dos y la escala fuera uno a dos
entonces tenemos que multiplicar por dos
para obtener los lados de este comedor
por dos acá y por dos acá entonces las
dimensiones nos quedarían
y 2 y de esta forma el área sería 4
sales y la escala es 2 entonces la razón
de las áreas es 4 a 1 muy bien qué
sucede si multiplicamos por 3 si la
escala es 3 entonces este lado que mide
1 ahora mediría 3 está también mediría 3
y de área nos quedaría 9 de esta forma
si la escala es 3 el área el área o la
razón de las áreas 69 entonces no
importa qué escala pongamos y aquí
ponemos una cierta escala entonces el
área va a ser el cuadrado el cuadrado de
esa escala que pusimos vale el cuadrado
multiplicado por el área original
entonces vamos a utilizar esa idea para
para ver cuál es la escala del plano al
comedor porque la información que nos
dan es la razón de las áreas entonces
déjame borrar por aquí voy a borrar
estos números
la idea es muy sencilla ahorita vas a
ver sea realmente realmente lo
importante es esto de que de que la
razón de las áreas es el cuadrado el
cuadrado de la escala vale entonces ahí
está borrado entonces la información que
nos dan es que es que el área es 1.600
veces 1600 veces el área en el plano va
entonces cuál tendría que ser la escala
bueno pues yo digo que la escala tendría
que ser 40 tendría que ser 40 porque si
multiplicamos por 40 entonces aquí nos
queda 40 verdad aquí nos queda 40 y
entonces aquí nos quedaría que el área
es 1600 y la razón de las áreas
quedarían 1600 y me puedes preguntar
cómo se te ocurrió poner el 40 bueno
pues el 16 es una pista muy grande
verdad sabemos que 4x4 es igual a 16 es
igual a 16
verdad y sabemos y sabemos que hay que
sacarle la raíz cuadrada a la razón de
las áreas entonces haciendo eso nos
queda 40 ok esto es un avance magnífico
ya conocemos la escala ahora sí déjame
hacer el dibujo del comedor con la
información que nos dan lo voy a poner
aquí abajo en color azul
entonces nos están diciendo que en el
plano en el plano la longitud es de 3
pulgadas 3 pulgadas vale y ya conocemos
la escala ya conocemos la escala sabemos
que el skal es de 40 entonces aquí en la
vida real
la longitud va a ser de 3 por 40
entonces hay que multiplicar por 40 y
aquí sería 120 pulgadas y ya casi
terminamos ya tenemos la longitud del
comedor en pulgadas pero necesitamos la
longitud del comedor empieza y para
pasar esta longitud a pies simplemente
tenemos que recordar que un pie un pie
es igual a 12 pulgadas 12 pulgadas y por
lo tanto multiplicando por 10 de ambos
lados 10 pies 10 pies es 10 pies es
igual a 120 pulgadas sale entonces la
longitud del comedor en pies es 10 es
igual a 10 otra forma de hacerlo es
haciendo la conversión verdad sabemos
que un pie son 12 pulgadas
entonces para convertir 120 pulgadas a
pies tenemos que tomar 120 120 y dividir
entre el factor de conversión 12 osea
estos son 120 pulgadas y dividimos entre
12 pulgadas por pie y esto nos queda lo
que acabamos de decir o sea 10 pies pies
muy bien